the one of the things that we are
watching as the draught approaches and
it's it's so funny because every few
days there's another quote there's
another development there's another
piece of the puzzle that confirms for me
and yes folks in Cincinnati you're not
gonna like this segment at all but I
believe that Joe burrow hopes the
Bengals don't draft him but he's not yet
ready to make a power play and by the
way in 35 minutes we're gonna have a
draft of players throughout history that
we believe should have made a power play
really only two ever did John Elway in
1983 and Eli Manning in 2004
I don't know that Joe burros gonna do it
Chris but you know every time he has a
chance to talk about this or someone in
his family talks about it no one has
said what are you talking about yes we
want to be drafted by the Bengals we're
from South East Ohio yes it's his dream
to play for the Bengals he wants to be
the first overall pick and he wants that
pick to be the Bengals they've never
said that now at one point Joe burrows
said and this was weeks ago
he's willing to play for whoever will
pay him to play but after Carson Palmer
came out and said what he said about the
Bengals not trying to win and then it
came out to Jordan Palmer Colson
Palmer's brother is working with Joe
burrow right and Joe burrow is on the
Dan Patrick show two days later and said
I just want to play for a team that's
committed to winning it wasn't all that
difficult to piece the puzzle together
and come to the conclusion that Joe
burrow if attached to a polygraph
machine and or given a healthy dose of
sodium pentathol would say I hope the
Bengals don't draft me and it's okay for
him to feel that what is why should
these guys just blindly submit to the
process he's embarking on a professional
career and if he doesn't want to play
for the Bengals he shouldn't have to
play for the Bengals although we know
that's not the way it is so they've got
to try to finesse this into maybe
getting the Bengals to realize on their
own that it's not in their best interest
to draft you Oboro yeah there's so many
things here I mean there really is you
know first off I would bet the Joe
borough and his family and his camp and
all that are a little bit like damn the
Bengals got the first pick damn it that
stinks but they're also I'm sure like
man we can we're gonna be the first pick
of the draft this is special there's a
lot of positive things there and he is
from southeast Ohio and
and has that backing and certainly can
draw people to the Cincinnati Bengals
Stadium and do all that and you know
have something to latch on to there as
you know being a guy for the franchise
and there is a lot of positives about
that for Joe burrow too you know also
the positives of like can you be that
guy to turn around an organization you
know can you be a and I you know I do
think he has the talent to be that I
understand the fearfulness of the
situation I do get it you know I think
Zach Taylor you know he's got it he's
got a bright future the bangles are
totally in a transition though I mean
they are rebuilding if we don't even
know what they're gonna do with AJ Green
yet so I understand all that it's just a
tough one because also you got to think
about this right Mike I mean if you're
Joe burrow and you go down this road
right and where you start to say I don't
want to be picked by them man scrutiny
comes and you get under put under a
microscope even to a greater degree when
you get into the NFL now because if you
do mess up people gonna go oh look at
that here's the guy that called the shot
didn't want to be on that team he stinks
anyways right you're gonna have to deal
with that as well so it's a tough
situation I'm sure but it's still a
great honor to be the number one pick of
the draft and that is a special thing
too but it's not an honor Chris no
here's the thing I was arguing with some
of my friends recently and yes I do have
friends contrary to popular belief about
the draft and how it's anti-american and
in no other industry does the employer a
group of employers come together and say
we'll take this guy we'll take this guy
and this notion that it's an honor
because one of my friends said hey if
they don't like it don't play it's like
wait the teams are drafting these guys
not because they just want to engage in
an act of charity
they are selecting guys they are
squatting on guys are gonna help them
win right these guys have a unique
highly marketable skill set that they
have honed to perfection and put
themselves in position to be so
desirable that someone would make them
the number one overall pick in the draft
it is not an honor to be told hey you
know what you may want to go play for a
different team you may want to live in a
different City you may want to work for
a different coach you may want to play
with a different group of teammates
but you don't get any say in that it's
an honor that we're gonna tell you where
your career is going to begin and I
think
one of the reasons he's treading lightly
and I was surprised yesterday Chris Joe
burrows said and this comes via the Fort
Worth star-telegram
I do have leverage well you've only got
so much leverage because if you decide
that you're not going to go to the
Bengals and the Bengals draft you your
leverage consists of sitting out the
entire season and re-entering the draft
yeah giving up a year of guaranteed pay
giving up that four year thirty six
million dollar fully guaranteed contract
that you sign is the number one overall
pick and reentering the process next
year when Trevor Lawrence is going to be
the first overall pick and you may slide
down the stack because out of sight out
of mind and oh by the way the Bengals
may draft you again next year right and
I wouldn't put it past my crown to draft
him twice so I don't know how much
leverage you really have that's the
problem yeah you don't have leverage cuz
you're stuck in a system where you get
drafted and your option is don't get
paid don't play football sit out for a
year and subject yourself again to this
inherently uncertain process where you
have no control over where you're gonna
go no yeah I mean listen from all those
out you I mean you're right you make a
lot of great points there's no doubt
about that I will disagree with you to
say it's it's you know it's not an honor
it's an honor to be the number one pick
in the NFL Draft you go down and they'll
you know the the lures of NFL history
forever as being that guy so that is
cool now the bangles thing certainly is
an issue yes they've been less than
they're dysfunctional you've heard me
say a number of times over the last few
weeks they need a rebranding you got to
get rid of that helmet in that stupid
uniform I'm sorry change it around do
something new Denver Broncos were open
for in Super Bowls they changed their
uniforms damn they've won two you know
they're just you got to do something to
change up the body the Patriots were
crap Bill Parcells change the uniforms
they don't lose ever since you know
there is something to that but either
way the other thing I'll throw in too
we're just to play like devil's advocate
with you you know these are a chance to
as a competitor yeah you want to be the
number one guy right I know you want to
go to a team that you feel like has a
clue of what's going on but you have a
chance in a guy like Joe burrow to
really be the savior of an
organization an organization that has
had no success and that is special to to
be that guy and I feel like we're coming
on a lot of young quarterbacks okay Kyla
Marie could have done this last year
what was there to be like oh I want to
go to the Arizona Cardinals they're
winners why cuz they went to an NFC
Championship game five years ago with
Bruce Arians wow they're winners yeah so
there's issues there too right wait wait
yeah everybody had Kliff Kingsbury there
I know that night I know you're right
yeah but here's the thing right
what was his alternative what was his
alternative well Giants high base buddy
well right he he had real leverage right
he had a ton of leverage he could have
said because for most of these guys
99.999% of them they don't have some
other professional sports now go play
that will pay them almost as much if not
more than what football will pay them so
he had real leverage he had the baseball
leverage but there wasn't really an
alternative to the Cardinals I think the
Cardinals made the most sense no you're
right there I don't know if there was
another team there yet to pick them and
do that and be involved I get it I I'm
here all I'm just trying to say is it
also could be a special opportunity you
know we saw you know you look at that
hey Russell Wilson you know Seattle was
never a winner I know they were relevant
but you know there he is now and they've
won a Super Bowl and they've been in
another one and he's like God in Seattle
you know right Tom Brady hey a little
New England what the hell were they
until he got there with Belichick and
they turned it around and now he's the
greatest thing in Boston sports history
you know Peyton Manning the Colts gosh
they wouldn't done crap since Johnny
Unitas aw they can't win they're not
winners he turned him around he's the
face of their franchise forever now and
even with Patrick mahomes I look at it
and just go you know Kansas City they
were kind of like had a stigma too and
he's reversed that so there are
challenges there you know for a Joe
borough to latch on to and maybe like as
well just as a competitor but I'm also
understand it is the bang goes and
you're right I've heard more horror
stories from players team coaches
whatever it may be about the Bengals and
how they're run compared to other teams
than any other teams so I understand the
concerns by Joe burrow or his family if
they're if they do have them I get it
they're real I mean it's it's not the
best look
bang goes put forward on a year-to-year
basis I mean it really is ridiculous to
think that a league with 32 independent
businesses this is not one unitary
business like some other sports leagues
are this is 32 separate businesses they
are able to come together and call dibs
on guys and you've got nothing you can
do or very little that you can do if you
don't want to play for that team if you
don't want to live in that city if you
don't want to have anything to do with
that coach then organization whatever
you've got no real alternative to it and
that's always gonna bug me even though
people think it's on American to call
the draft on American if you think about
it and I've convinced stats of this it
took some time the draft really is on
American guys should be able to decide
where they want to work and there are
ways to ensure that there would be
competitive balance even if teams can
decide where they want to go not the
other way around
Steve Bartowski the first number one
overall pick in the draft that I ever
became aware of because that's back when
I started following football 1975 draft
who Steve Bartkowski number one overall
pick the Atlanta Falcons Bartkowski
thanks that Joe burrow should pull an
Eli Manning and make that power play
because number one the bengals are a bad
organization in bartowski's opinion and
number two Bartkowski played for a bad
organization he said he spent more time
in the hospital recuperating for an
injuries in his first three years then
he did throwing touchdowns and if it's
the bengals for joe burrow I'd pulled an
Eli Manning I said you've got a chance
to do that that's happened John Elway
set the tone then the Mannings delved
into it after Eli was picked by San
Diego and it really is amazing to me
because they were the San Diego Chargers
at the time they're not anymore it
really is amazing to me that more guys
haven't done it that's why today's draft
is gonna be guys who should have done it
now Bo Jackson kinda did it Yeah right
when it went he did choose baseball over
the Buccaneers yeah but then the next
year the Raiders took a flyer on him he
decided to play football and you know
until until he had the hip replacement
he was on track to possibly be a
two-sport hall-of-famer
but look I don't know where this is
gonna go from here it's funny though to
hear people like Jimmy burrow Joe
burrows dad and Robin burrow his mother
say we don't know where this came from
this is all coming from the fact that
Joe has yet to come out and say I want
the bengals if the bengals want me I
want the bengals I hope the mengel's
take me I can't wait to play for the
bengals I can't
wait to wear that ugly-ass helmet I want
to play for the Bengals until he says
that this is still gonna be out there so
people who think we're like we're we're
making something up and there's a lot of
Bengals fans and people who cover the
Bengals who think their ship is finally
coming in and people are actually gonna
care about the things they write about
because the team's gonna be relevant
when they have jobber oh and they get
angry when we suggest they may not have
him wake up it's obvious Jo burrow hopes
the Bengals don't take him he hopes they
trade his rights to the Dolphins it is
obvious the question is Chris where does
it go from here where do you think it
goes from here do you think he's gonna
make a power play at something I don't I
know I just I don't get the sense that
it's in him and again I don't know him
but I'm going off of just things where I
see him talking on TV his family
everything like that you know I you can
see there's certainly reservations you
can see that you're right I mean the way
they're talking is not being like yes I
want to go number one to the Cincinnati
Bengals let's do it yeah I understand if
there's reservations this is a huge
moment in their life I get it you know
because you do get stuck in the wrong
situation the team gone in the wrong
direction you know just like any player
you could be really good and you get
stuck in that situation it just doesn't
matter you know you're you're gonna be
looked at you're gonna look like a less
than average player when the
organization and team around you are
less than average as well so it is big I
get it but I also look at a guy who just
you know had the guts to leave Ohio
State go to a place like LSU change the
culture there forever right to wear it
LSU they can't ever throw the ball
they've never thrown the ball in the 170
years of existence and all of a sudden
he's throwing the ball better than
anybody we've ever seen in the history
of college football for LSU
I think he's gonna welcome this
challenge when all said and done even
though he might not be sitting there
just loving the fact of it he does have
a chance to like go in there and be the
John Elway of Cincinnati and have every
car dealership in town and have four
restaurants in town you could be that
guy in Cincinnati cuz they're that
starving for a winner and that's to me
you know one thing to look at just as
far as a positive thing if you're a guy
like Joe burrow one last
point yeah and burrow has pointed this
out it's still early in the process
right he hasn't taken any visits yet
it's possible he goes and visits the
Bengals and decides I want to be here I
like the direction this is heading right
or you go to Cincinnati and decide he
doesn't want to be here and it was Eli
Manning who decided after visiting the
Chargers in 2004 that he didn't believe
the front off and the coaching staff are
on the same page about whether they
wanted him that's what made him not want
the Chargers and art she ended up being
the face of that effort so Eli had some
distance from it but it was the visit
that made Eli believe San Diego was not
the place for him so the visit and when
you compare and contrast Cincinnati with
Miami with other cities he may visit
other teams he may spend time with he's
gonna develop an opinion as to whether
or not he wants to play for the Bengals
so maybe he's just being hesitant for
now he'll make a decision later it'll be
one of the stories of the off see
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports